my immediate family is  libertarian conservative but my extended  family is not and so that has been  difficult for sure same  yeah and so it's  how do you handle it do you i usually  try to prioritize the relationships over  like minuscule political disagreements  and that's what i've tried to do  but  their response has just been to  completely walk away and shut you out  uninvite you from things that sort of  thing so it's been difficult but i don't  know what is your experience been  um i usually don't bring up certain  topics too yeah family members that i  know don't hold the same opinions i like  it it doesn't matter if it's gonna upset  that person i don't need to change their  mind like you don't need to change  everybody's mind so i usually avoid it  uh for people  who don't talk to me anymore i just  don't care like yeah at all i don't care  i don't have enough energy to to care at  even a little bit